[Music]
there are places out there you can't
find on any map
they're not gone
they're just lost
hey kid i'm a little young for a
bartender aren't you a little old for
prom aren't you
everything in here why the map this path
fernand took the sail around the world
you know your history
it's the biggest treasure that's never
been found five billion easy
to go i think you're here because you're
your brother well you know my brother's
here
kelly doesn't have any friends i should
know i'm one of them
[Music]
you are a collector well i dabbled i
don't dabble
my family has been looking for this
portion for a very long time so much
blood
i'm pretty sure he's just threatening to
kill me don't touch your ear like that
you look like an idiot
you have no idea who you partnered with
i've been dreaming about this stuff
since i was a kid my brother's saying
left one final clue
guess i'll keep
oh my god i should never come out to
play with that big boy's man because
you're about to get a proper scottish
welcome
what
oh crap
exclusively in movie theaters
july 20th
1969.
that's one small step
[Music]
in school you were taught that apollo 11
lost contact with the world for two
minutes
[Music]
not true
they found something on that day
that they kept him for 50 years
and
now
it's too late to stop
in breaking news the governor has just
ordered the mass evacuation of the
entire west coast
moving to higher ground it's the only
possible chance of surviving
stay away my brothers and sisters
stay awake
this planet
has suffered five extinctions
this
is going to be the sixth
oh he dead
you know we are just inside the moon
that might be the greatest sentence
anyone's ever said
[Music]
[Music]
thomas
[Music]
you seem particularly triggered right
now can you tell me what happened
i've had dreams that weren't just dreams
am i crazy
we don't use that word in here
[Music]
hi
have we met
[Music]
and
one pill makes you small
and the ones that mother gives you
don't do
anything
at all
[Music]
time to fly
[Music]
[Music]
the only thing that matters to you is
still here i know it's why you're still
fighting
and why you will never give up
you don't know me
no
dead
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
after all these years to be going back
to where it all started
back to the matrix
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ever since i got bit by that spider
i've only had one week
where my life has felt normal
that was when you found out
[Music]
when you botched that spell where you
wanted everyone to forget the peter
parker spiderman
we started getting some visitors
[Applause]
from every
universe
hello peter
you're not peter parker
i'm sorry what was your name again dr
otto octavius
[Laughter]
wait no seriously what's your actual
name
there are others out there we need to
send them back
so scooby do this crap you know all this
is kind of your mess i know a couple of
magic words myself starting with the
word please
please scooby-doo this crap
you're flying out into the darkness
to fight ghosts what do you mean
they all die fighting spider-man
it's their fate
i'm sorry kid
yeah me too don't
but there has to be another way there
isn't
they're a danger to our universe
you know to take this away from me
peter
you're struggling
to have everything you want
while the world tries to make you choose
this is all my fault i can't save
everyone
[Applause]
what's happening
they're starting to come through
and i can't stop them
december 17th exclusively in movie
theaters tickets on sale november 29th
spider monday
[Music]
i'm looking for someone who can help me
gain an audience with the czar perhaps
you can be of assistance
i only make decisions when my stomach is
full or my balls are empty
well thank god dinner is being served
[Music]
small things can grow into big problems
[Music]
we are the first independent
intelligence agency
while governments wait for orders
our people take action
welcome to the club
you're going to need a suit
very clever
time to dance
[Music]
stop [ __ ] about
[Applause]
[ __ ] this gentleman's [ __ ] i'm gonna
love calling you
[Music]
i wish we'll see
[Music]
please
hit us up
[Music]
get out of here
[Music]
fear is a tool
when that light hits the sky
[Music]
it's not just a call
that's a warning
[Music]
i can take care of myself
if this continues it won't be long
before you've nothing left
i don't care what happens to me
it's only gonna get worse for you
oh take it easy sweetheart
hear everything they say
maybe we're not so different
who are you under there
inventions
what's black
and blue
and dead
all over
dick
i got you
[Music]
bond any thug can kill
i have to know i can trust you
[Music]
well i understand double those have a
very short life expectancy
you're a kite dancing in a hurricane mr
bond
is this really what you want
alone
[Music]
we used to be able to get into a room
with the enemy
and now they're just floating in the
ether
when our secret finds its way out it'll
be the death of you
oh my god target enough people
remember people become the weapon
who is he james
you don't know what this is
james want
license to kill
in love with madeleine swann
i could be speaking to my own reflection
only your skills die with your body
and life is all about leaving something
behind
isn't it
come on bond where the hell are you
[Music]
if we don't do this
there will be nothing left to say
i have to finish
you're a great mom
i don't know i'm fine with trevor
but with phoebe
she really keeps me on the outside
that's normal she's an awkward nerdy kid
maybe a new home can be an opportunity
to start fresh i just wish he'd get into
some trouble there's still time
[Music]
what are you doing here in summerville
anyway we're completely broke and our
grandfather left us this creepy old
farmhouse in the middle of nowhere
your father wasn't much of a homemaker
he could hardly keep the power on
you're saying he left us nothing
well i wouldn't say nothing
[Music]
you went with station wagon it's the
only one that had an engine
what is happening here
somehow
a town with no fault lines is shaking on
a daily basis
maybe it's the apocalypse
egon came out here for a reason
are you troubled by strange noises in
the middle of the night
you experience feelings of dread in your
basement or attic
if you or any of your family ever seen a
spook inspector or ghost
[Music]
oh my god
you guys hear that
something's coming
all city
it's like the walking dead
we're
we're closed
[Music]
i need to exchange some books
come on
scarlett's kid how is your mother
i haven't seen her in 15 years
let's get you into a good book
you'll need a jane austen
a virginia woolf
and an agatha christie
for reading
sam your talents are needed
[Music]
somebody stole from us
he's crazy enough to steal from the fun
is it done there's a change of plan they
have an eight-year-old girl i can't
leave her to die
sam you killed the wrong people you're
no longer under our protection some bad
men are coming to hurt us we have to go
where it's safe
hi mom
my grandmother
god no
girls i think i see a ghost we need
weapons
give the kill order i'm gonna do
terrible things to you girls
we're gonna bring the sky down
i'm gonna make a little noise
so what's the plan
i called as an uber are you kidding me
nope
oh that's really unfortunate
if i get out of this alive
i'm coming for you
you are an incredibly impressive young
woman there's not a single person on
earth i'd rather kill people with
thanks mom
are you a serial killer what
you kill people
yes and you've killed more than one that
is cereal
it's more complicated than that
i'm sorry brother
sorry that i brought you into this i
just wanted things to be the way they
used to be
that's my brother will i could use some
help my wife needs to search me this is
real life how's that right you put your
life down on the line for this country
you leave your family your home how much
do you need 231.
how about more
32 million and i need an extra man i
came to you for a loan look if i ever
got you anything that i couldn't get you
out of it's time for you to do something
for your family
what can i do for officer we're just
doing a transfer from the back i'll let
you in in 20 minutes uh if i could just
get it done real quick because i'm on
the clock promise not to rob the place
seriously because that would be bad for
my job
my problem okay all right all right come
on okay
[Music]
let's go dude you are all gonna have the
greatest story to tell at dinner tonight
out
don't shoot a car
lock everything down
nothing gets out
[Music]
what do you want just gonna borrow it i
got a cop shot i gotta get him to the
hospital i'm gonna need you to help us
why don't you help us we're doing
hostages now
we're not crashing into this ambulance
we got a brother cop on board do you
have empty experience come back to the
eyes you're a soldier yeah
we are trying to save you
you think you're so tough with that gun
yo daddy relax
i gotta get back to my life for my son
does your wife know you're all banks
we're not the bad guys
we're just the guys trying to get home
we don't get to walk off into the sunset
danny everybody knows how dangerous you
are do you
you get your heels out of here now
i'm gonna get you back home little
brother i'm gonna get everybody home
[Music]
the world has a way of changing
[Music]
we heard y'all needed a little love out
here
y'all ever thought about the wild
missions we've been on we've taken out
planes trains tanks i'm not going to
think about the submarine
[Music]
hey man we got cars flying in the air
[Music]
who is he
jacob is
dom's brother
been a long time little brother
you always say never turn your back on
family
but you turned your back on me
now your little family
is in my world
[Music]
he's got his own private army we need
help
[Music]
okay this is a bad time to mention this
but i don't drive
[Music]
brother against brother this should be
interesting
[Music]
crank it all the way up get back with
the soldiers
man we messing with magnets now
if you broke the wake up
wow
and now
you spend the rest of yours
not today
really duct tape you acting like we on
our way to home depot
i don't wanna die
[Music]
robert dubois
is in prison for putting superman in the
icu with a kryptonite bullet i'm not
joining your suicide squad
we'll see
my court date is coming up i miss
wallace and maybe you can help me out
you're stretching in my door
stand down
stand down
i wouldn't take such extreme measures
this mission went more important than
you could possibly imagine
are you in
or out
good
let's meet your team
it's okay i'm not okay
each member is chosen for his or her own
completely unique set of abilities
[Music]
hey guys sorry i'm late let's go number
two good to
know this thing a dog a dog what kind of
dog do you think it is mate i'm gonna go
with afghan hound oh my god is it a
werewolf y'all next time
yo let me out yeah he's not a werewolf
okay he's a weasel he's harmless i mean
he's not harmless he's killed 27
children but you know
[Music]
your mission
is to destroy every trace of something
known only as project starfish any
questions
starfish is a slang term for a butthole
think there's any connection
no
no
all
right let's get it
this is suicide well that's kind of our
thing i'm a superhero
[Music]
i'm going to get you out of here alone
[Music]
ratatouille what do you got bird
now now it stay off the calm
you need a doctor
i am a doctor
i should have died years ago
people all over the world have my
disease from here
to find a cure we have to push the
boundaries take the risks
[Music]
if you're gonna run
do it now
dr michael morbius you've been missing
for two months when you're a stranger
then you were found on a container ship
that washed up off a long island
when you're alone
what did you do to yourself doctor
i wish i knew
i went from dying to being more alive
than ever it worked
not exactly i have increased strength
and speed
and some form of bad radar
what else can i do
[Music]
there are limits there has to be there's
something inside of me
he wants to hunt
and consume blood
and you control it
i don't know
we haven't had anything this good since
that thing in san francisco
the other half wants to control you hey
uh dr mike you and i should stay in
touch
i'd do anything to save a life
but i don't know what i'm capable of
you save lives you don't take them
are you here to heal the world
or to destroy it
who the hell are you mad i
am i know
i'm just kidding it's dr michael
morvious at your service
[Music]
your instructor is one of the finest
pilots this program has ever produced
his exploits
are legendary
what he has to teach you
may very well mean the difference
between life
and death
your reputation precedes you
i have to admit i wasn't expecting an
invitation back
they're called orders maverick
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning aviators this is your
captain speaking today's exercise is dog
fighting two versus one he's gotta be
kidding
[Music]
smoke in the air
[Music]
there's something happening to me
there's something awakening in my mind i
can't control it
what did you see
there's a crusade coming
[Applause]
do you often dream things that happen
just as you dream them yes
the test is simple
remove your hand from the box
and you die
what's in the box
pain
[Applause]
you inherit too much power
you have proven you can rule yourself
now you must learn to rule others
something none of your ancestors learned
my father rules an entire planet he's
losing it
he's getting a richer one
you'll lose that one too
arrakis is a death trap
[Applause]
this is an extermination
[Applause]
they're picking my family off one by one
let's fight my demons
an animal caught in a trap will nor off
his own leg to escape
what will you do
[Music]
i know you
[Applause]
[Music]
one day
the legend will be born
[Music]
all of civilization depends on it
the future i can see it
[Music]
i must not fear
[Music]
fear is the mind killer
my lord duke
where the fear is gone
only i will remain
go go
[Music]
my name is guy sunday should be warm and
sunny just a scattering of drive-bys and
i live
in paradise
i've got a best friend this is the
greatest cup of coffee of all time
mondays am i right joe you said it guys
and i work at the bank
i thought i had everything i needed
but then i met her
everybody down on the ground
everybody accept you
please i have a cold fish there's
something inside you guys i don't want
something inside me i expected you to
just follow the rules but you are so
much more than that put these on okay
fine
oh my
what are god trick glasses or something
guy there is no easy way to say this
this world it's a video game you're not
real
please
and the guy responsible for this world
was going to destroy it
you've met god yes he's an absolute
troll trolls exist
buddy if we're not real doesn't that
mean that nothing you do matters i am
sitting here with my best friend trying
to help him get through a tough time now
if that's not real i don't know what it
is i know this world is just a game for
this place these people that's all i
have
so i'm not gonna be the good guy thanks
guys i'm gonna be the great guy
well enjoy your lifetime supply of
virginity if you go
this whole good guy routine is ruining
the game
terminator it's the first time i've ever
driven a car before i really wish you'd
mentioned that yeah
that actually hurt my hand we can save
our world but we have to fight together
[Music]
nope
[Applause]
i can't die
i'm never gonna die
[Music]
where lady here
we should be out there snacking on bad
guys
i am a predator
i need to be free you have got to get
control of your aggression but we will
get hauled off into area 51.
live in my body you live by my walls
i'm sorry i don't know what came over me
please let me fix it so i can fix it
again
you are a loser
eddie brock
i want to give you my story
people love serial killers
cletus why me that's mine
it's yours and what's yours
is mine
i have tasted blood before and that is
not it
all i ever wanted in this world
is carnage
oh [ __ ]
where you going
that is a red one you need to come out
right now
i will let you eat everybody
i promise oh yeah
betty
you feel like home to me
like family
oh wow you could just say i'm happy for
you that was going to be us hey i'm
happy for you
no
god i'm so sorry i'm sorry just doing
some serious couples counseling
that story that they told us about in
training
about george washington's first female
spy during the revolution
they called her agent 355
because they didn't want the world to
know her real name
but her legacy lives on
[Music]
we're the top agents from around the
world
american
british
german colombian chinese
but now we have a common enemy
they can start world war three
from simple reach of their keyboard so
we need to join forces
it's like half the cia's most wanted
always such a tough guy
i'm not an agent i'm a therapist they
thought i would give you my secrets do
you have secrets
we put ourselves in danger so that
others are not
i'll handle the guns
are you in therapy i should be
you're the best in the world of what you
do you have cameras in your jewelry
comes in your earrings you bump i grab
the target is on the move
you're not going in there alone we go
together
i have a family i cannot do this anymore
the bad guys are out there right now
you go home
you bring them with you
are you under control are you no
black cars all black everything i've got
four more agents out on the street i
counted six but thanks for the tip
i like the new team we're the three five
five
[Music]
[Music]
throughout my life
the ten rings gave our family power
if you wanted them to be yours one day
you have to show me you are strong
enough to carry them
you are a product of all who came before
you
the legacy of your family
you are your mother
and whether you like it or not
you are also your father
i told my men
they wouldn't be able to kill you if
they tried
glenn i was right
here's just a criminal
who murders people
be careful how you speak to me
start a new life
but i could never
escape his shadow
my son
you can't run from your past
[Applause]
is this what you wanted
[Music]
you got this
thank you
this is our only chance
we have to take
[Music]
we need kong
the world needs him
to stop what's coming
in this child
she's the only one he'll communicate
with
i knew that they had a bond
she had nowhere to go so
i made a promise to protect her
and i think that in some way
khan did the same
[Music]
[Music]
it's godzilla
[Music]
these are dangerous times
godzilla's out there and he's hurting
people and we don't know why
there's something provoking him that
we're not seeing here the same opinion
the myths are real yeah
there was a war
and they're the last ones standing
[Music]
tell me
something you can go
anywhere you want right
any timeline
and the universe
[Music]
why do you want to stay
and fight to save this one
you change the future
and you change the past
are you in
oh
every story has a beginning
discover the origin of evil
why are you back here clear your
conspiracies weren't true when we were
kids they're not true now
we need to expose umbrella
watch this
i'm afraid claire i'm afraid of what
they're gonna do to this town
see umbrella they have an incident i'm
talking chernobyl if you know what i
mean
people are getting sick
you gotta help us claire let the world
know what's really going on
[Music]
we have to contain this time
[Music]
sometimes
[Music]
should split
[Music]
take a deep up and i get real high at
night
[Music]
[Music]
we're gonna take umbrella down
[Applause]
the annual purge will conclude in three
two
one
thank you for your participation
we survived
all police and emergency services have
been reinstated
all crime including murder
is now illegal come on let's get to work
one night only rest of the year is
peaceful
[Music]
help me
help me
the purge is over please
no it ain't
this is insane
nobody hear the sirens
there's no crime anymore
anything else
you rich can't hide behind your steel
walls no more
powerless how's that feel is the real
purge the forever purge
hurry up they're coming
come on follow me
there's nowhere safe to go
no way to get help
oh my god we gotta find another way to
get out of here
[Music]
[Music]
this country's gonna collapse
mexico is opening its borders for the
next six hours let's go
we're in this together
uh
[Music]
does this translate
[Music]
why'd they put you in a fire tower
[Music]
well i'm just lucky i
guess read the wind wrong
[Music]
i should have gone to them
[Music]
then you've been dead too
that's our job
[Music]
hey stop i'm not gonna hurt you i wanna
see where the blood's coming from it's
not my blood
you in trouble
anyone else in trouble
my dad said
if anything happened i should find
someone i could trust
are you someone i can trust
we promise absolutes
act accordingly
[Music]
give them something else to worry about
listen
you really want to die for this kid
take it deep breath
hold it
and lay back
what happens next
[Music]
got something
looks like we lost him
dr aldeway you have a patient who goes
by the name of dylan forrester he's one
of my most interesting most promising
patients
when was the last time you spoke has he
done something you mean attempted murder
then yeah well that's progress
is there anything you need to tell me
no you're not the same man you used to
be deep dee's younger brother professor
sean forrester is dead the funeral is
today you got a lot of nerve coming here
get me someone in the washington state
police the fbi he broke his ball short
of him
move
you know the routine
i didn't expect him to be here so soon
you can't be the fbi not exactly we
search the house first and found out no
one dies until we find out what they
know
i'm trying to do my best here
don't be too hard on yourself
oh sure and i'll shoot you both
so now do you understand what happens
when you don't help me jacob
find me way back in
what aren't you telling me
sean must have told you what's here on
the island
you're being shot at
oh yeah
[Music]
did you really kill people uncle bees
they were really bad people
[Music]
thomas ernest mother
ex-cop
convicted of murder in a burglary gone
wrong
apex is quite simple
they're hunters
you are the prey
what's the price if i kill all the
hunters
win and i can guarantee your freedom
[Music]
my good hunters
welcome find me a real challenge
who the hell is that
do we get a refund if we kill this guy
within an hour
you're good kid i'm better than good i'm
bacon and eggs on sunday morning
malone has defied death more times than
most navy seals
simply put the universe just can't seem
to kill him
man like that never should have come to
a place like this
let's remind malone who is the hunter
and who is the
i prey that's all i do
that won't be happening
bring me the head of thomas malone
you're only logical choices to beg beg
me to let you live
this ain't that kind of fight even
better
do you know anything about wine a little
you're a lightsaber i'm chris
skye
two sudden adventures it's a sudden
adventure
[Music]
hey get away from my car man we don't
want any
wait wait wait wait wait
ladies you're two weeks behind on the
rent again you're not gonna say anything
explain where you were all night
i saw something on the news lisa it's
your roommate
scotty should probably contact the
police that would be stupid of me why
expecting a package
how's the knee dude i do good work don't
i
everything goes loverboy
stripping me down
that's scary right i need all your
passwords and security codes
are you going to get chris so you want
me to call the police he's right here
my name is christopher decker there's a
woman in my house she's imprisoned me
against my will she's trying to steal my
identity she wants to kill me
thank god you came back chris thought i
might lose you forever i'm better now
you should have seen a look on your face
[Music]
[Music]
stay back
afraid of the dark
i love the dark
i tell people my sister moved out west
you're a science teacher
your husband
he renovates houses
you're thinking about moving but you're
gonna wait until the interest rates go
down that's not my story
[Applause]
before i was an avenger
i made mistakes
[Applause]
and a lot of enemies
[Applause]
his call signs taskmaster
he controls the red room they're
manipulated
fully conscious but no choices
i should have come back for you
how many others are there
enough
[Applause]
we have to go back to where it all
started
so they never do that to anyone again
we're family
we fight with you
you won't win i've always found it best
not to look into the past
okay you got a plan or should i just
stay dug and cover my plan was to drive
us away gloria plan sucks
[Music]
at some point we all have to choose
between what the world wants you to be
and who you are
i made my choice
i'm done running
[Applause]
[Music]
here's what's gonna happen natasha don't
slouch i'm not slouching you're going to
get the back hunch listen to your mother
oh my god
all right enough all of you i didn't say
anything that's not fair
well they say kids never come by unless
they need something
dad i need your help
i'll get my coat
30 years in the future we are fighting a
war
our enemy is not human
and we are losing we need you to fight
i will be back and i love you chickpea
seven days from now when you're sent
into that war
you won't be fighting for your country
you'll be fighting for the world is it
all right yeah going to war stop talking
listen sorry i mean when i'm nervous at
talk i'm like 97 on the nervous scale
that should be fun
welcome to the future
you and your unit are now in 2051.
they're everywhere we are food and they
are hungry
our enemy is smarter
faster
and stronger than you can possibly
imagine
do you want to see something really
dangerous if you like literally that's
all i've been doing since i got here but
okay
within the next few weeks the human
species won't disappear from the face of
the earth nothing we do here matters
that's where you're wrong
i don't believe that one bit
together we can stop this war
from ever happening
this is my opportunity to give this
world a second chance
second chances are really hard to come
by
light them up
i'm not gonna hide
i'm gonna fight it's not even loaded
yeah well yeah it's not loaded it's a
pressurized cabin why would i load it in
the cabin the bullet goes in thing and
everybody sucked out
please don't call me that i'm going to
keep your engine i got my money then
you'll get it back
frank goes me money
[Music]
we're headed up river to la grimas de
cristo
i gotta be honest it's not a fun
vacation
are you gonna beg me to turn back
10 000 to bring you there live
dead it's 15 000.
why should i pay more debt
dead i'd have to carry you that's a lot
harder lady
here we go
[Music]
i got you
[Music]
it's impossible
[Music]
what's up with the picture
that
is a 70 to 75 bmw csl
thing of beauty say you're back 135k
i'm saving up
gonna get one how's that going for you
considering you just got fired had a
couple g saved
only another 133 000 to go
[Music]
i know a guy
nath clark hymn is cripped in about 14
stick ups he's slick
he's the fourth man
collection
never done a robbery before
[Music]
if you don't know why you're doing this
then you need to get out the car robbing
a bank
you know that's mad right honey yeah
because it's a police bank east bank
[Music]
for the artists still
set up where you gonna hit and win swell
mob two to four no more
guns load of the blanks doesn't matter
people see guns they automatically think
death the getaway car in album messing
around mess around
[Music]
he's playing in the back goes wrong
you're probably gonna have to kill
somebody to get out security guard woman
maybe even a kid
who are you 12 i'm 16. don't flinch
you are surrounded
you shot him they're trying to keep him
alive right now if he dies i'm gonna
kill him
did you come here to be a murderer i
thought you came here to rob a bank you
gotta be in this do you really wanna
kill a little girl
is that why you came here today
man all i really want is to buy a 70 to
75 bmw csl 3.0 and drive away from here
forever well god damn
[Music]
it's his son
his only son
[Music]
i need to know who's responsible
i'll kill my son
we've deployed large amounts of time
money
and effort
in the search for justice not good
enough it's got to be an inside job
you're going to have to go undercover
there's an army truck driver
we have a new addition may i introduce h
cash trucks can be dangerous
[Music]
they're serious
leave this
just do what he says
you work for suck my [ __ ] dick what
did you say
i said
we need a different approach boss it's
not any of the usual suspects
what do you want me to do
i can do it two weeks you know what i
wish you could do in 20 years
are you gonna give your knife
i need to face
we do understand
resourceful
not serious i am
on a dudebury grudge
if he's not a cop
what is he
he's a dark [ __ ] spirit
[Music]
you're gonna tell us everything you know
i'm not telling you a mother
you can electrocute him all day it'll
only make him angrier i on the other
hand will tell you everything really
michael bryce was trying to put his past
behind him you need to forget
bodyguarding repeat after me no
bodyguarding no
then he got pulled back in let's go
jesus to protect this homicidal nut bags
wife what is he doing here i said get
anyone but michael rice i believe it's
pronounced thank you
in four days all of you loved was burned
they're planning a full-scale cyber
attack do not scoop this up but we are
definitely gonna screw this up
i promised my therapist no bodyguarding
let's not do that guys let's just focus
i got it no it's fine you guys just you
guys have had him
maybe feather the break a bit
i need you to protect us
good time to have a baby
[Music]
[Music]
we need guns
we need boats we need them are you ready
to get your freak on
what that came out wrong not together
with us that also came out wrong
now let's go do what we do and blow some
things up
it must be your powerful asexuality that
makes you such a good listener
we just acknowledge that not only are we
safe this really feels like a newbie
we're not even invited to this thing
aren't we nope
uh mom's coming benjamin
have you two been smoking dope yeah
why can't you keep him under control
sons and anarchists mrs given
for generations the given and wrath card
families had
a blood feud it was never about business
your son is trespassing
it was personal
mary raskar ben gibbon
do i need to explain to you why this is
unacceptable
end it
it was an instant scandal
you take care of my problem i'll grant
you my daughter's hand
take care of him
looks like me and you're gonna dance
how do you want to die
i want to die in a gunfight
the choices they had made had led them
to this very moment
the fallout
it's not gonna be pretty
let's get out of here i always thought
of my life like i was living in my movie
i'm gonna be the star of your movie
this presents me with an issue keep your
friends close and your enemies close the
right dad enough
we're gonna piss a lot of people off
do you have a death wish
something that excites you
dudes pretty much conform or die
honestly i'd rather die
put the fear of god in it
will try to stop us
i'll protect you for how long
for as long as you want me to how about
forever
there's the next house you get in you
get the stuff i tell you to and you get
out i'll bring my garage this time
[Music]
let's do it
[Music]
here nobody move sit down
well hey there buddy
now why are you running
there's only one person that could have
done this
he's the gardener
gardener he's military he's a killer and
so are all of you
they've seen my face they all died
what are you gonna do
save your family
[Music]
if you want something done properly
do it yourself
so uh gardening have you always enjoyed
it
yes
i've been chasing their boss forever
this might go south
hell of a day isn't it partner
[Music]
up here
go go go
[Music]
you better go preach don't you touch my
baby
come on big boy
come on big boy
you won't need to leave
please
who are you i'm a cop these two just
shot my partner down the road
run
i need you to get to safety these people
will kill you this is my farm they don't
belong here
who are these guys they're drug dealers
scumbags you're my prisoner till my boss
gets here i'm finishing this alone
i will defend this land
this is certainly a development
we came here to kill or did any of you
not get the memo on that
because evidently this cop did
i expect you and i are so different
nothing like you i got shot today and
i'm tied up
and you still hit like a [ __ ] you need
my help that's the house that i shared
with my wife
that is all i've got left all right
let's go save them
i got your back
we killed
or be killed
run i gotta finish this
runner arrest wrong place wrong time i'm
gonna be the guy that's gonna kill you
i'm not going anywhere
this is my farm
on your feet
senior chief john kelly
is more dangerous and effective
than any man we have in the field
[Music]
the only thing he has more than kills
are medals
[Music]
somebody would like to talk to you
john if you're done in there we need you
to get back in the field
senior chief kelly
it appears you have a common enemy with
the united states
they took everything from me
my family
i got nothing left
their plan is a series of strategic
attacks all over the world
we have to respond i need to be on that
team lieutenant commander greer you lead
the mission i'm leaving out the playing
field cia doesn't support any further
investigation into your wife's murder
battlefield he had no right
to take so much from me
this is a gold missionary
they know exactly where we've been
what the hell is going on here
[Music]
welcome to the most extraordinary and
unforgettable experience available on
this planet
tens of thousands of visitors a month
we've only just begun
nature's spectacle presented as
entertainment
i mean only a lunatic would build a
world-class resort on a ticking time
bomb of molten earth right
the mountain's waking up
i need time to study it we're all going
to be fine
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
five years ago thanos erased half of the
population of the universe
but the people of this planet brought
everyone back with a snap of a finger
the sudden return of the population
provided the necessary energy
for the emergence to begin
how long do we have
seven days
we're eternals
[Music]
we came here 7 000 years ago
to protect humans from the deviants
why didn't you guys help fight thanos or
any war all the other terrible things
throughout history
[Music]
we were instructed not to interfere in
any human conflicts unless deviants are
involved
by who
[Music]
we need to find the others
i haven't seen some of them for
centuries
hi
hello
this is what the end of the world looks
like
at least we have front row seats
you know what's never saved the planet
you're sarcasm
we have loved these people since the day
we arrived
when you love something
[Applause]
you protect it
[Applause]
you can't protect
[Music]
any of them
[Music]
i bet you've built a perfect safe house
what's this even made of vibranium
fall collection
ikea
[Music]
first learned about this seven years ago
on a mission in brazil to capture a
wanted fugitive
when we got there it tore through our
unit in seconds
the target has superhuman abilities
[Applause]
[Music]
it had the same marking you do cole
it's a birthmark what do you mean he was
born with it
it's not a birthmark cole
means you've been chosen
throughout history different cultures
all over the world
reference a great tournament
world champions
that dragon marking
i think it's an invitation
to fight for something known
[Applause]
as mortal kombat
these are your champions i'm sonia
that's kano
i'm luke
name's jax
conglomerate
the fate of earth is in our hands
no matter how many of my people you put
in the ground
we will not
fail kill them
[Music]
i
am
zero
[Applause]
get over here
you [ __ ] beauty
you